In this lesson, I want to take a look
the mathematics behind mortgage loans.
It will not really be a lesson for finance.
In fact, it's more about math.
In my mind, however, it affects one of the most fundamental
questions I ask
for quite some time now.
It is known that we take loans when we want to buy houses.
Let's say you're pulling $ 200,000 in a mortgage loan.
It is secured by your home.
You will pay it for 30 years, or we can say,
that it is 360 months.
Because if you normally pay it every month,
the interest is charged each month.
Let's say you pay 6% interest.
This is annual interest and is usually distributed
on a monthly basis, i. 6% divided by 12.
That is, it is 0.50% per month.
Per month.
When you get such a loan, your broker
or your banker, will look at a table,
or introduce the numbers into a computer program.
And he will tell you "Okay, your installment follows
to be $ 1,200 per month. "
If you pay these $ 1,200 a month for 360 months,
at the end of those 360 ​​months you will pay $ 200,000.
Plus the interest that has accrued.
But this number is not so easy.
Let's show an example of how mortgage actually works.
On the Zero Day you have a $ 200,000 loan.
You have a $ 200,000 loan.
You do not pay any contributions.
You will make your first installment
after a month from today.
This amount will be obtained from the 0.50% set.
That is, a decimal fraction equal to 0.005.
After a month with such interest, this amount will increase
200 000 * (1 + 0.005).
Then you will import those 1200 dollars.
The amount will be minus $ 1200. Maybe I should write it like 1.2K.
Right now I just illustrate the idea itself.
What remains for the next month,
will be redefined by 0.50% or 0.005.
Next month, you will return again
and you'll bring in those $ 1,200.
Minus $ 1,200.
This will happen 360 times.
That is, you will continue to do so. You can be
if you really try to express yourself
this number, at the end of the period you will have one huge one
an expression that will contain 360 parentheses
right here. Finally, everything will be equal to 0.
Because, after making the last installment,
then the house is paid.
How, however, is the monthly installment determined?
Let us mark it with p.
Is there a mathematical method to calculate it?
To do this, let's take a closer look at the task.
Let L say that L equals the sum of the loan.
The amount of the loan.
Let i be equal to the monthly interest rate.
Monthly rate.
Let n be the number of months,
for the repayment period.
Then, we want p to be equal to the monthly
payment, ie. monthly payment.
Part of it is the interest, part of it is the principal.
However, the amount you will pay each month,
to repay the loan and the interest is the same.
So this is your monthly installment.
This is the same phrase I just wrote down here.
I wrote it in a general way. Starts with the amount of credit L.
After one month it will increase as
multiply the sum by 1 + i. In this case i
is equal to 0.005.
Then you pay a monthly sum equal to p, ie. we record minus p.
This is therefore the end of the month.
Now, however, you have some amount left out of your loan.
It is calculated for the next month.
You will then reintroduce the amount p.
And this process will be repeated 300 times, or n times,
because it is still about the common look.
You will therefore have n number of parentheses.
And after the process is repeated n times, then all this
will be equal to 0.
My question, the one I want to answer
in this lesson, is this: How do we find the number p?
If you know the amount of the loan, the monthly
interest rate and number of months,
how will we find p?
It really does not look like an easy algebraic one
an equation we can solve.
Let's see if we can make some transformations.
Let's see if we can write the phrase in another way.
Let us use an example in which n is equal to 1.
If n equals 1, then the situation looks like this.
You take the amount of the loan, multiply it in one month,
i. 1 + i, and then make the monthly installment.
This is a credit that is paid for a month.
That is, after a payment, the amount of the credit is covered.
Nothing left for a surcharge.
If we now want to find p, we can exchange the two sides of the equation.
P is equal to L * (1 + i).
We divide the two sides of the equation to 1 + i. P is obtained
1 + i is equal to L.
You might say, "Hey, here we found p.
Why are you doing this?".
I do it to show you
model that will be produced.
Let's see what happens when n equals 2.
n equals 2.
Then you start with the original credit.
Calculated for one month.
You make your contribution.
Then there is some amount of the loan.
It will be calculated for another month.
Then you make your second installment.
This mortgage loan contains only two installments.
And now it's paid off!
You do not have the amount of credit left.
Both the principal and the interest are paid.
Let us now find p.
I will write p with some color.
Here's what p will do in pink.
Let us add p to both sides of the equation, then exchange them.
Therefore this green p will be equal to this one
expression here.
It is equal to L * (1 + i), minus this pink p.
It's the same p. I just want
to show you how it looks algebraic.
Minus this pink p, 1 + i.
If we now divide both sides into 1 + i, we get p
on 1 + i is equal to L * (1 + i), minus this pink p.
Let's now add this pink p to both sides of the equation.
Pink p, plus p on 1 + i,
is equal to L * (1 + i).
Now we divide both sides into 1 + i.
Pink p is obtained on 1 + i, plus the green p, the same p,
which is already divided into 1 + i.
Now it will be divided again into 1 + i.
That is, it will be divided into 1 + i square. And equal to the loan L.
Something interesting is happening.
Perhaps you should look at the present value lessons.
In this case, you get the monthly installment,
divide it into interest, and get the credit amount.
You make each contribution. You divide her
at 1 plus monthly interest,
the number of months.
You are actually taking this value
of the installments and again get the loan amount.
You can check it if you want
to practice algebra.
You can do the same with n equal to 3.
I will not do it because I do not have the time.
If you choose n to be equal to 3, then you will get,
that credit is equal to p on 1 + i, plus p on 1 + i of square,
plus p on the (1 + i) third degree,
If you have time, I encourage you to prove it
for yourself, using the same approach we applied here.
You will see that it will get a little scary.
There will be many edits of the phrase,
but it will not take you far.
Generally, I hope I showed you that we can imagine
the amount of credit as the present value of all contributions.
Then we can say that the amount of the loan - if I summarize,
for n months instead of some number -
is equal to the following. I will take p as a common multiplier.
Equals p on 1 on (1 + i), plus
1 on (1 + i) per square, etc.
n number of times, finally plus 1 on (1 + i) of degree n.
Now maybe you see what's going on.
This is a geometric progression.
There is a way to find the sum of a geometric
progression with any number of members.
Geometric progression.
As I said at the beginning, this lesson will be
for applying a sum of members of geometric progression.
It is equal to the sum of 1 on (1 + i). Here I will use
some other letter. In degree j, with j starting from 1.
From the first degree - ie. here is this article - from j equal to 1,
to j equals n.
That's what this sum is equal.
Let's see if there is an easy way to calculate the amount.
We do not want to collect 360 times.
You can do it and get a number. You divide
L on this number and get p.
But there should be an easier way to do it.
Let's see if we can simplify the expression.
For easier calculations, let me make a substitution.
Let's say r is equal to 1 on (1 + i).
And let this whole sum be equal to s.
This sum is equal to s.
If r equals any of these members, then
s will be equal to the following. This will be equal
to r of the first degree. I record r at first degree.
This will be equal to r of square,
because if we pick up a numeric square, we get 1 again.
Then, we have plus r of a square, plus r of a third, etc.,
until we get to plus r at degree n.
I'll show you a little trick.
I always forget the formula, so this is a good way
to find the sum of the geometric progression.
In fact, this can be used to find the sum of infinite
geometric progression. In this case, however, we work
with the end one.
Let's multiply s by r.
What will be equal to r?
If you multiply each of these members by r,
the first one will get a square.
The second will be the third.
You keep doing so until
you do not reach r at r - 1. You multiply it by r
and you get r at degree n.
Then you multiply r on degree n by r and you get
plus r at r + 1.
Here are all the members multiplied
by r, just putting them to the same degree.
What you can do now is to get this one out
a green expression of this purple expression.
And if we form s minus r * s, what will happen?
I just get this line out of this line.
Here we get r1 minus 0, ie. r at first
degree minus nothing here.
Then r gets a square minus r per square and is destroyed.
r of the third minus r of the third are destroyed.
All members up to r at grade n minus r at grade
are destroyed. Then stay that one
last article here.
That's why it's a nice trick.
Remains minus r at degree n plus 1.
Now we export s.
The s * (1 - r) is obtained, so far I have delivered,
is equal to r of first degree minus r at degree n plus 1.
If we now divide both sides into 1 - r,
we will receive the requested amount.
The requested amount is equal to r, minus r at degree n + 1, on 1 - r.
This is equal to the amount requested, like
we defined r this way.
And now we can re-record all this crazy formula.
We can say that the loan amount is equal to the monthly amount
contribution multiplied by this expression.
I'll save it in green.
Multiplied by r minus r of degree n + 1.
All this is on 1 - r.
If we now want to express p, we multiply both sides
by the reciprocal of this expression and we obtain that p is equal to the amount of the loan,
multiplied by the reciprocal of that expression.
I record it in pink because it's reciprocal.
1 - r on r - r of degree n plus 1.
Where r equals this expression here.
And we are ready!
This is the way to find out what
is equal to the contribution of your mortgage loan.
Let's apply it.
Let's say your credit is $ 200,000.
Let the annual interest rate be 6%,
which is 0.5% per month; the same as 0.005.
This is the value of the monthly interest rate.
Let's say it's credit for 30 years, so n will be
equal to 360 months,
Let's calculate what we get.
The first thing we want to do is find,
what is the value r.
Let's find the value of r.
r is equal to 1 on 1 + i.
Let us take 1, divided by 1 + i, i. plus 0.005.
This is equal to the monthly interest, at half a percentage point.
Then, 0.995 is the value of r.
Let me save it, 0.995.
This calculator does not save variables, so
I'll just write this down here.
r is equal to 0.995.
We just used this here.
I miss some precision,
but I think it's OK.
The important thing here is to give you the basic idea.
What is the monthly installment?
Let's multiply the $ 200,000 credit. $ 200,000.
1 - r, ie. 1 - 0.995, divided by r, equal to 0.995, minus 0.995.
Now n is equal to 360 months, so it will work out
360 plus 1 or 361. Something I definitely can not
to think in mind. Now we close the brackets.
And the final answer is approximately $ 1,200.
Indeed, if you want absolute precision, you will get it
slightly less than this value, but will be approximately $ 1,200.
That's how we managed to find
the actual monthly installment from the mortgage.
Therefore p is equal to 1200 dollars.
It was really a very unusual approach to find
something people face every day.
But now you know the mathematics behind it. You don `t need to
you are dealing with a table or an electronic one,
to get the number through an experiment.